zur konferenz der jahresbericht der
wehrbeauftragten eva högl
den 64 kolleginnen und kollegen die mit
viel erfahrung mit viel sorgfalt mit
engagement und vor allen dingen auch mit
herzblut jeden tag die anliegen der
soldatinnen und soldaten bearbeiten und
zum jahresbericht natürlich beigetragen
haben der jahresbericht bildet wie jedes
jahr auch dieses mal wieder das ganze
soldatenleben ab und zwar von ausbildung
bis zulagen ich habe dieses jahr auch
neue themen drin ich habe zum beispiel
ein kapitel klima drin weil ich der
auffassung bin dass auch die bundeswehr
da ihren beitrag leisten kann und
leisten sollte und da 2021 ein jahr der
olympischen spiele war habe ich auch das
thema sport aufgenommen nämlich den
wunderbaren sport den hochleistungssport
förderung durch die bundeswehr die auch
zu medaillen führt und aber auch die
rahmenbedingungen des sportes in der
truppe ansonsten beleuchtet sie wissen
dass der jahresbericht ist immer eine
ansammlung von mängeln fehlern und
versäumnisse und im besten fall
grundlage dafür dass das ministerium und
der deutsche bundestag das zum anlass
nimmt um an lösungen und für
verbesserungen zu arbeiten
aber ich wüsste im jahresbericht auch
dieses jahr wieder viele gute beispiele
auf dinge auf die wir stolz sein können
was in der truppe erreicht wurde oder
was auf gutem weg ist wir bearbeiten im
amt der wehrbeauftragten jedes jahr
ungefähr 4000 vorgänge im jahr 2021
waren das genau
3967 vorgänger und da fand waren
2606 persönliche eingaben von
soldatinnen und soldaten
das entspricht ungefähr den zahlen des
vorjahres außerdem greife ich ja neben
den eingaben dinge auf die soldatinnen
und soldaten mir bei meinen
truppenbesuchen vortragen und auch die
sogenannten meldepflichtigen ereignisse
werden zum teil von uns aufgegriffen und
weiterverfolgt ich bin dankbar dass im
jahr 2021 ich trotz corona viele
begegnungen hatte und auch viele
truppenbesuche möglich waren sie sehen
das auch im jahresbericht die auflistung
ich konnte über 60 truppenbesuche machen
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar und endlich
konnte ich ja 2021 auch in die 1 das
gebiet reisen was 2020 wegen corona
nicht möglich war und so war ich im juli
in litauen und im november in mali und
niger denn diese truppenbesuche auch in
den einsatzgebieten ersetzen nichts kann
durch nichts ersetzt werden kein
telefonat keine mail keine
video-konferenz ersetzen die
persönlichen eindrücke die vor ort sehr
wichtig sind ich bezeichne das jahr 2021
als das jahr der bundeswehr von der
amtshilfe bis zum ende des afghanistan
einsatzes war die bundeswehr in dem
ganzen jahr da wo sie gebraucht wurde
professionell und zuverlässig und unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten dass es gerade
in diesen tagen sehr wichtig noch einmal
hervorzuheben garantieren frieden
freiheit und unsere sicherheit und
putins völkerrechtswidriger krieg in der
ukraine führt uns allen vor augen wie
real dieser frieden bedroht ist und das
bedeutet auch dass die bundeswehr bei
ihrem kernauftrag nämlich bündnis und
landesverteidigung in der nächsten zeit
auch und jetzt aktuell auch schon so
gefordert sein wird wenig und deshalb
meine damen und herren brauchen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten die besten
rahmenbedingungen und das betrifft das
material das betrifft das personal und
die infrastruktur
und sie können sich vorstellen dass ich
mich sehr gefreut habe und ich begrüße
es ganz ausdrücklich die ankündigung des
bundeskanzlers 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen zu ermöglichen und den
verteidigungshaushalt zu erhöhen das ist
in schweren zeiten eine gute nachricht
für die bundeswehr denn mit diesem geld
soll die volle einsatzbereitschaft
wieder hergestellt werden mit diesem
geld kann finanziert werden was in der
truppe dringend benötigt wird und als
wehrbeauftragte sage ich ganz deutlich
die priorität muss zunächst einmal
darauf liegen die ausstattung der
soldatinnen und soldaten zu verbessern
unsere frauen und männer in der
bundeswehr brauchen alles was sie am
mann und an der frau haben müssen um den
auftrag auszuführen und deswegen muss
das geld erstens in der truppe ankommen
und zweitens auch zügig ankommen das
heißt neben dem geld müssen auch die
beschaffungsverfahren zügiger auf den
weg gebracht werden und durchgeführt
werden die prozesse müssen beschleunigt
werden und das vergaberecht muss auch
vereinfacht werden ich war sehr
will man so deutlich sagen entsetzt als
ich zb in mali und niger war aber auch
in litauen und festgestellt habe dass
nicht mal im einsatz alles parat ist wir
kennen die debatte auch aus afghanistan
aber es ist so dass es auch im einsatz
an der ausstattung mangelt oder auch am
großen gerät es wird dann zwar zügig
auch alles beschafft aber auch in mali
habe ich festgestellt dass die westen
nicht immer rechtzeitig da waren oder
der transportpanzer fuchs nicht so
einsatzbereit war damals als ich da nur
50 prozent wie es sein sollte wir haben
den grundsatz train es soweit und das
heißt sowohl in der ausbildung in der
übung als auch im einsatz muss alles
vorhanden sein um den dienst gut ausüben
zu können und deswegen reicht es auch
nicht wenn das große gerät zu 77 prozent
einsatzbereit ist das ist eine
verbesserung gegenüber dem vorjahr aber
das ist noch nicht genug ein wichtiges
thema ist das thema personal in der
bundeswehr und da muss ich sagen das ist
wirklich sehr positiv dass trotz corona
der bestand an personal in der
bundeswehr ungefähr gleich geblieben ist
im jahr 2021 zum jahresschluss 183 1695
soldatinnen und soldaten
das ist eine gute nachricht dass das
möglich war und davon sind 26 1606
frauen da sind wir bei einem prozentsatz
von 12,85 das geht ganz langsam voran
das wird ganz langsam mehr aber wir sind
da noch lange nicht am ziel und ich habe
mir auch erlaubt in diesem jahresbericht
2021 frauen das thema frauen in der
bundeswehr etwas hervorzuheben weil wir
2021 genau 20 jahre frauen in allen
teilen der bundeswehr hatten und
verbindet das mit zwei botschaften
frauenanteil muss steigen es braucht
mehr frauen in der bundeswehr und die
frauen müssen auch führungspositionen
einnehmen bis 2021 soll die bundeswehr
aufwachsen auf 203.000 soldatinnen und
soldaten und das heißt dass die
bundeswehr gut sein muss in den themen
personalgewinnung personalentwicklung
und personalbindung das ist eine mammut
aufgabe für die bundeswehr
offene stellen gut zu besetzen und vor
allen dingen auch jungen leuten gute
angebote zu machen aber auch mit einem
realistischen bild nicht nur mit schönen
plakaten sondern auch mit einem
realistischen bild denn meine damen und
herren das ist mir sehr wichtig und das
war sie aus vielen gesprächen mit
soldatinnen und soldaten es ist wichtig
auch zu vermitteln soldat soldaten zu
sein ist kein normaler job ist nicht
vergleichbar mit verwaltung oder einer
kfz werkstatt sondern die soldatinnen
und soldaten stehen im zweifel für den
auftrag mit ihrem leben ein die
bundeswehr wird immer älter das zeigt
der jahresbericht auch wieder wir sind
2021 bei einem durchschnittsalter von
33,1 jahre das heißt es ist insbesondere
auf der aufschlag junge leute
anzusprechen und deswegen habe ich mir
auch genau angeguckt das neue programm
freiwilliger wehrdienst heimatschutz wo
junge leute im jahr 2021 waren es 8 143
7 monate lang im dienst leisten in der
bundeswehr und ich bin besorgt dass die
abbruchquote bei 25,6 prozent lag wenn
dieses programm fortgeführt wird dann
muss es auf jeden fall deutlich besser
werden ich komme zum thema infrastruktur
dass es auch ein wichtiges thema für
soldatinnen und soldaten
wir haben einen investitionsbedarf in
der bundeswehr bis zum jahr 2034 von 19
milliarden euro und wir wissen dass die
landesverwaltung die dafür im
wesentlichen zuständig sind alle
zusammen pro jahr eine milliarde euro
umsetzen können daran sieht man dass wir
einen ganz gewaltigen investitionsstau
haben und ich habe mir bei allen meinen
truppen besuchen immer die situation
angeguckt ich gucke mir schöne dinge an
die gut in schuss sind aber auch eben da
wo es sanierungsbedarf gibt das betrifft
unterkünfte das betrifft sportanlagen
sportplätze aber auch schwimmhallen wenn
die kampfschwimmer in eckernförde seit
über zehn jahren keine schwimmhalle
haben in der sie trainieren können dann
gibt es ein problem und ich habe mir
erlaubt auch an die 16
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten zu schreiben weil
das eine gemeinsame kraftanstrengung
sein muss von bund und ländern um das
bauen bei der bundeswehr zu
beschleunigen und die kasernen gründlich
zu sanieren das jahr 2021 ist geprägt
von dem ende des afghanistan-einsatzes
und dieser einsatz hat die bundeswehr
verändert das war eine zäsur fast 20
jahre der größte schwerste intensivste
einsatz mit
93.000 soldatinnen und soldaten die dort
im einsatz waren 59 haben in afghanistan
ihr leben verloren und viele soldatinnen
und soldaten sind verwundet an körper
und seele zurückgekommen dieser einsatz
hat die bundeswehr verändert und
deswegen sage ich dass hier auch nochmal
so deutlich ist es wichtig dass er
gründlich aufgearbeitet wird ich begrüße
dass der deutsche bundestag geplant hat
eine enquete kommission einzurichten und
ich hoffe dass er nicht durch die durch
den krieg in der ukraine und
tagesaktuelle geschehnisse
völlig aus dem blick verloren wird
sondern diese enquete kommission diese
aufarbeitung ist wichtig auch für
laufende und künftige einsätze denn wir
müssen intensiv darüber diskutieren in
welchen teilen der welt soll die
bundeswehr eingesetzt werden mit welchen
partnern mit welchen zielen mit welchen
mitteln in welchem umfang mit welcher
dauer und das meine damen und herren
diese fragen und diese antworten vor
allen dingen erwarten die soldatinnen
und soldaten vom deutschen bundestag ich
möchte kurz hervorheben die evakuierungs
operation ende august das war eine
grandiose leistung der bundeswehr in elf
tagen hat die bundeswehr
5347 personen ausgeflogen darauf können
wir wirklich sehr stolz sein und dafür
sehr dankbar sein aber es gibt auch eine
lehre insbesondere aus dieser operation
das nämlich künftig der schutz und die
sicherheit von orts kräften anders
organisiert werden muss das betrifft
auch laufende auslandseinsätze es
braucht ein geordnetes verfahren und das
ist auch ein plädoyer und eine lehre aus
diesen erfahrungen
ich möchte gerne den blick lenken auf
ein thema was auf 2.021 wichtig war
nämlich das thema rechtsextremismus in
der bundeswehr das beschäftigt uns
weiterhin im jahr 2021 hat das bad 5
189 fälle bearbeitet und wir hatten 252
meldepflichtige ereignisse die zahlen
steigen
und ich führe das darauf zurück dass die
sensibilität in der truppe gestiegen ist
dass es mehr meldungen gibt und dass es
auch im besten sinne gute kameradschaft
wenn etwas angezeigt wird es gibt ein
konsequentes vorgehen in der bundeswehr
und ich will zwei beispiele nennen als
wir in litauen im sommer 2021
vorkommnisse hatten oder auch hier in
berlin beim wachbataillon im oktober
haben wir gesehen dass konsequent
ermittelt wurde aufgeklärt wurde schnell
sanktioniert wurde und dass die
maßnahmen die ergriffen wurden auch dann
gewürgt haben das gilt im übrigen auch
für das kommando spezialkräfte des
heeres das ksk hat uns ja auch intensiv
beschäftigt hat den maßnahmenkatalog
aber soweit ich das auch begleitet
verfolgt und beurteilt beurteilen kann
auch den maßnahmenkatalog gut umgesetzt
und ich kann auch heute sagen dass k s k
s auf einem guten weg wir brauchen einen
dreiklang aus aufklärungs sanktionen und
prävention und dazu ist es auch gut dass
es neue sicherheitsüberprüfungen gibt
vor allen dingen bei der reserve das
wird im oktober in kraft treten denn bei
der reserve haben wir wirklich auch noch
handlungsbedarf und wir haben im jahr
2021 gesehen dass die arbeitsgruppe aus
fahrrad und dem bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz über 1000 fälle 1333
fälle bearbeitet haben nicht alle
bestätigen sich aber das zeigt dass der
intensiv dran erarbeitet wird und ich
will aber auch schließen zu diesem thema
mit einem echten ärgernis das muss
besser werden erstens die
sicherheitsüberprüfung verfahren müssen
zügiger geführt werden aber insgesamt
die verfahrensdauer muss deutlich
schneller werden bei den truppendienst
gerichten und auch die entlassung von
soldatinnen und soldaten die auffällig
geworden sind muss auch deutlich
vereinfacht werden und da hoffe ich auch
dass sich in der nächsten zeit etwas
verbessert mein letztes thema ist die
amtshilfe die amtshilfe corona aber auch
insgesamt die amtshilfe das beschäftigt
und belastet die truppe das geht jetzt
seit zwei jahren und ich will natürlich
hervorheben dass die soldatinnen und
soldaten dort grandioses leisten sie
sind hochprofessionell
sie sind zu recht sehr beliebt sie sind
sehr zuverlässig und wir können alle
stolz und dankbar sein dass sie bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie aber auch beim
hochwasser im reinen und in bayern mit
angepackt haben und tatkräftig geholfen
haben man mag sich gar nicht vorstellen
wie die pandemie bekämpfung gewesen wäre
ohne die vielen soldatinnen und soldaten
2021 hatten wir zu spitzenzeiten mitte
februar
19.000 soldatinnen und soldaten
zeitgleich im einsatz und gegenwärtig
sind immer noch 3900 soldatinnen und
soldaten in der amtshilfe gebunden
allein 2500 in den gesundheitsämtern und
meine damen und herren das ist so dass
die einsatzbereitschaft dadurch nicht in
frage gestellt ist aber sie ist deutlich
verzögert das habe ich mir im jahr 2021
an vielen stellen berichten lassen und
nachgefragt und auch bei den verbänden
die jetzt in der vorbereitung sind für
die enev sagen dass sie ungefähr ein
halbes jahr corona preisschild haben
weil nicht alle ausbildung so
stattfinden konnten nicht alle übungen
und das ist tatsächlich eine bugwelle
die die bundeswehr da vor sich
herschiebt deswegen sage ich diese
amtshilfe muss jetzt enden wir haben
jetzt gerade vor dem hintergrund des
krieges in der ukraine in der bundeswehr
andere aufgaben die kräfte müssen parat
stehen und für die amtshilfe in der
korona bekämpfung sind jetzt zivile
gefragt ich schließe mit dem thema
gesellschaft weil das für die werbe
auftakt sind natürlich auch ein
wichtiges thema ist und ich beginne
damit zu sagen meine damen und herren
die bundeswehr braucht vor allen dingen
eins sie braucht interesse sie braucht
natürlich auch respekt anerkennung
wertschätzung und dank aber es gibt auch
genügend möglichkeiten und das ist in
der demokratie total in ordnung streitig
über die bundeswehr und ihre rolle und
ihren einsatz zu diskutieren und über
verteidigungspolitik im allgemeinen und
ich hab 2021 im jahr der bundeswehr
beobachtet dass es deutlich besser
geworden ist die amtshilfe hat dazu
geführt dass viele kontakt mit
soldatinnen und soldaten hatten die
evakuierungs operation hat dazu geführt
dass viele stolz waren und das anerkannt
haben und der krieg in der ukraine so
traurig wie das ist das heute hier so
sagen zu müssen führt natürlich auch
dazu dass viele feststellen wie dankbar
wir sein können dass wir die bundeswehr
haben und deswegen schließlich nochmal
mit dank erster dankeschön für ihr
interesse und nochmal für die einladung
hierher und ich danke auch ganz zum
schluss nochmal unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten für ihren dienst für frieden
freiheit und sicherheit und freue mich
jetzt auf ihre fragen und anmerkungen
herzlichen dank vielen dank frau hügel
die erste frage geht an herrn müller
holger möhle bonner general anzeiger
frau hügel ist jetzt ja den befund von
einigen generäle dass die bundeswehr
nicht fähig ist das land und das bündnis
mit zu verteidigen schließen sie sich
dem an was bedeutet das für den fall wir
wissen ja nicht was hier läuft das der
ukraine krieg auf nach europa
überschwappen sollte und sind sie dafür
die wehrpflicht zu wieder zu aktivieren
danke
ich mache mal in der reihenfolge ihrer
fragen herr müller zunächst einmal wenn
sie beispielhaft nehmen die äußerung des
inspektor heeres von general mais die
bundeswehr sei blank dann muss ich als
wehrbeauftragte sagen dass das natürlich
ein sehr emotionaler beitrag war und
generals auch auf bestehende defizite
hingewiesen hat aber die bundeswehr ist
einsatzbereit und ich habe ja eben auch
geschildert dass es natürlich defizite
gibt die auch beseitigt werden müssen
und wir haben vor allen dingen jetzt
gesehen dass es unter umständen sehr
schnell gehen muss mit der
einsatzbereitschaft die kräfte wurden
sehr zügig verlagert jetzt
verstärkungskräfte nach litauen es ist
geplant in die slowakei auch kräfte zu
verlegen und außerdem wurden kräfte
verlegt nach rumänien vor dass für das
er politik deswegen muss die kalt staat
fähigkeit wenn ich den begriff auch mal
so verwenden darf der bundeswehr
deutlich besser werden wir müssen also
alles parat haben aber die bundeswehr
ist trotzdem einsatzbereit und kann ihre
verpflichtungen in der nato auch
übernehmen der zweite punkt wir setzen
alles dran alle die da verantwortung
tragen dass die dass dieser krieg in der
ukraine dass die nato nicht involviert
wird in diesem krieg das ist ganz ganz
wichtig wir können uns das glaube ich
alle nicht vorstellen was das heissen
würde wenn die nato involviert wäre und
das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig und das
gebot der stunde dass die nato
vorbereitet ist und sich gut schützt und
verteidigt und bereit ist und abschreckt
auch aber nicht in diesen krieg
hineingezogen wird und das dritte ist
sie haben ja sicherlich wahrgenommen
dass ich mich gerne eine einer debatte
darüber diskutieren wie junge menschen
sich auch in unserer gesellschaft
engagieren sollten und könnten und die
bundeswehr natürlich auch ein bereich
ist den ich gerne attraktiv für junge
menschen machen möchte aber eine debatte
über die wiedereinführung der
wehrpflicht und die rückgängigmachung
der aussetzung zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt vor dem hintergrund des
ukraine kriegs ist für mich eine
theoretische debatte die wir jedenfalls
jetzt in dieser situation nicht weiter
hilft aber ich freue mich über eine
künftige debatte darüber wie die
bundeswehr mehr gutes personal bekommen
kann und wie auch jungen leuten gute
angebote gemacht werden können sich in
unserer gesellschaft zu engagieren
herr jung
hügel in ihrer pressemitteilung fordern
sie dass das geld was jetzt auf den weg
gebracht wird für die bundeswehr
sinnvoll investiert wird können sie uns
mal die definitionen von sinnvoll hier
geben und was wären nicht sinnvolle
investitionen jetzt
zunächst einmal ist es so dass es
wichtig ist dass es jetzt keine wie auch
immer gearteten wunschlisten gibt
sondern es ist so wenn man eine
bestandsaufnahme macht was fehlt der
bundeswehr und da geht es ja um
investitionen in material von
ausstattung bis zu großen gerät dann ist
schon klar was ist braucht und so kommt
die summe von 100 milliarden euro ja
auch zustande das heißt all das was der
bundeswehr jetzt fehlt ich beginne mal
mit kälte und nässeschutz helme über
schutzwesten ich gehe weiter bis zur
nachtsichtgeräte funkgeräte und dann bis
zum großen gerät also boote und schiffe
für die marine schwere
transporthubschrauber nachfolge tornado
zur sicherung der nuklearen teilhabe
also da gibt es eine ganze menge was
dringend notwendig ist und schon
identifiziert ist und wenn das jetzt in
die truppe investiert wird dann ist das
definitiv sinnvoll und als
wehrbeauftragte sage ich auch mal wenn
es um eine zeitliche priorisierung geht
dann bin ich sehr dafür erst mal das
anzuschaffen was auch zügig beschafft
werden kann was nicht jahrelang
entwickelt werden muss und da fange ich
mal mit der unmittelbaren ausstattung
von soldatinnen und soldaten an wenn das
so gemacht wird bezeichne ich das als
sinnvoll
was wäre denn nicht sinnvoll und wir
haben ja in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten immer wieder gesehen dass
milliarden an euro in der bundeswehr
manche sagen versichert ist wie kann das
in zukunft verhindert werden
also nicht sind zwar unsere
strukturellen grundlegend nicht sinnvoll
wäre es wenn man jetzt anfängt irgendwas
neues zu entwickeln was dann 2050 oder
so zuläuft und die bundeswehr dann davon
profitiert sondern all das was jetzt
schon in der entwicklung ist was schon
geplant wird das kann jetzt über die
jahre mit dem sondervermögen finanziert
werden und zu der bereitstellung dieses
wichtigen geldes für die bundeswehr
braucht es natürlich eine überarbeitung
der beschaffungsverfahren also das
gesamte system der beschaffung ist zu
behäbig es wird häufig werden goldrand
lösungen entwickelt es wird nicht das
geschafft was am markt verfügbar ist
oder was unsere partner längst nutzen
das sind alles gute vorschläge die
ministerin ist auch mit vorschlägen
schon in die diskussion gegangen zum
beispiel das europäische vergaberecht
auch so zu nutzen dass man auch über
ausnahmen gehen kann oder die summen zu
erhöhen dass man bis zu 5000 euro auch
ohne eine ausschreibung vergeben kann
sondern eine direktvergabe machen kann
das sind alles sinnvolle und gute
beiträge um das geld auch schneller in
der truppe wirken zu lassen und dass es
schneller bei den soldatinnen und
soldaten ankommt
die
rückholung der ortskräfte war hier
häufiges thema sie schreiben dass im
rahmen ihrer möglichkeit sie alles getan
hätten um das zu befördern konkrete
frage haben sich darüber auch einmal mit
markus kroth jahren persönlich
ausgetauscht das partnerschafts netzwerk
organisiert hat er ja als aktiver
offizier sozusagen direkt einer ihrer
ansprechpartner sein könnte
vielen dank ich habe mich nicht direkt
mit händlern ausgetauscht weil der in
der damaligen zeit sehr gefragt
war ja ich habe aber mit personen aus
dem patenschafts netzwerk gesprochen und
ich habe mich auch noch ein bisschen aus
meiner alten tätigkeit als
stellvertreter fraktionsvorsitzende der
spd für den bereich innenpolitik
intensiv mit dem innenministerium dem
außenministerium und dem auswärtigen amt
und dem verteidigungsministerium
auseinandergesetzt und über dass
ortskräfte verfahren gesprochen auch mit
dem damals zuständigen staatssekretär
intensive gespräche gehabt mit
abgeordneten also das thema ortskräfte
hat mich wirklich ganz intensiv
beschäftigt obwohl ich nicht wirklich
unmittelbar als wehrbeauftragte für
diese personen zuständig bin ich war ja
auch in der aufnahmeeinrichtung ich habe
mit verantwortlichen hier im land
gesprochen auch mit der damaligen
sozialsenatorin und ich habe auch als
ich auf dem flug nach taschkent war mit
der damaligen ministerin und dem
generalinspekteur darüber gesprochen
dass ich gesagt habe und das wiederhole
ich hier auch nochmal für laufende
einsätze und für künftige einsätze
brauchen wir ein anderes ortskräfte
verfahren es muss klar sein welchen
personen wir schutz und sicherheit geben
und das darf nicht so ablaufen wie das
leider beim ende des afghanistan
einsatzes war also ich war tatsächlich
sehr engagiert in diesem bereich bleibe
es auch aber persönlich mit herrn
christian das war ja ihre frage habe ich
leider nicht gesprochen aber ich nehme
das zum anlass das man nachzuholen und
mit ihm kontakt zu suchen vielen dank ja
nachfrage sie sagten eben welche
personen schutz geboten werden soll und
welchen nicht welches sind die wo sie
sagen nehmt ihn nicht es sind also die
kriterien und wenn ich das noch fragen
darf wie weit sind wir bei der
rückholung ihrer einschätzung nach von
orts kräften und anderen gefährdeten
personen aus afghanistan wie hoch ist da
der nachholebedarf
also zunächst einmal
finde ich es wichtig all die personen
die uns geholfen haben im jeweiligen
einsatz land mit den auftrag gut zu
erfüllen das betrifft alle personen aus
dem bereich entwicklungshilfe und soweit
ich spreche jetzt aber nur für die
bundeswehr alle die irgendwie verbindung
verträge welche gestalt auch immer diese
verträge hatten aber die geholfen haben
entweder das camp abzusichern ja oder
bei der dolmetscher oder so und da bin
ich auch tatsächlich dafür ein einen
begriff zb einen weiten familienbegriff
ich habe mit vielen personen aus
afghanistan gesprochen die gesagt haben
der familienbegriff wenn es ab 18
volljährig ist und dann die person nicht
mehr zur familie gehört das entspricht
nicht unseren afghanischen
familienbegriff das heißt man muss einen
deutlich weiteren begriff haben als wir
vielleicht in unserer westlichen welt
haben zum beispiel von familie und dann
finde ich es auch sehr wichtig und ich
habe mich zum beispiel mali und niger
darüber informiert dass die personen vor
ort ordentliche verträge haben ja und
zwar manchmal nicht nur direkt mit der
bundeswehr sondern wir beauftragen ja
auch örtliche firmen und dann finde ich
ist es auch unsere verpflichtung zu
gucken dass die personen die beauftragt
werden wiederum von den firmen dass wir
da nicht die augen verschließen sondern
auch hingucken was für arbeitsverträge
haben die also ich bin da eher 5 weiter
ging's aber natürlich können nicht alle
die irgendwie mal kontakt hatten und
keinen vertrag oder keine beziehung
hatten können nicht alle tatsächlich
auch geholt werden aber das ist ja dann
die einzelfallprüfung die dann erfolgen
muss und ich kann ihnen jetzt keine
auskunft geben weil ich keine eigenen
erkenntnisse hatte und dass wir jetzt
spekulation und unseriös inwieweit das
auswärtige amt das innenministerium das
bmz jetzt dran sind auch noch weitere
personen aus afghanistan
nach deutschland zu holen und ihnen
schutz und sicherheit zu geben ich lasse
mich aber fortlaufend informieren dass
das läuft und wir haben auch immer mal
einzelpersonen die sich bei uns wenden
und wir geben das dann weiter auch
insbesondere ins auswärtige amt der
capitano
über die reform des vergabe und
vergaberechts und beschaffungswesen
reden wir jetzt vielen vielen jahren was
macht sie zuversichtlich
dass das jetzt gelingen könnte wie
könnte das gelingen welchen pusch könnte
es durch den krieg gegen die ukraine da
geben also dass man überhaupt in der
lage sein wird dieses viele geld in den
kommenden jahren auch wirklich
auszugeben und was den krieg in der
ukraine angeht glauben sie dass es da
auch eine bewusstseinsveränderung gibt
allgemein auch im bundestag in ihrer
partei bin ich an die nukleare teilhabe
denke die war ja auch
sehr umstritten bis hin in die
fraktionsführung ändert sich da jetzt
etwas
ich beginne mal damit dass ich ihnen
sage dass ich bisher auch immer gesagt
habe 50 milliarden euro im
verteidigungshaushalt ist eigentlich
eine komfortable finanzierung der
bundeswehr und daran hat man auch
gesehen dass die probleme tatsächlich in
den strukturen legen wenn wir aber jetzt
alles auf summen was die bundeswehr
braucht dann kommen wir eben auf die 100
milliarden und diese enorme summe die
zur verfügung steht in den nächsten
jahren die ist eine riesenchance da für
sie jetzt auch gut und wie ich eben
schon mal gesagt habe sinnvoll
auszugeben denn wir hatten ja sogar in
den vergangenen jahren auch mal ein
problem das die 50 milliarden oder
damals fast 50 jahren von der bundes vom
verteidigungsministerium von der
bundeswehr gar nicht komplett ausgegeben
wurden das war ja im vorletzten jahr
eine gute nachricht das gesagt würde
alles geld wurde jetzt ausgegeben warum
bin ich zuversichtlich dass das jetzt
besser geht erstens wir können die
ausnahmen die der europäische die die
europäische das europäische recht im
vergaberecht vorsieht auch dadurch etwas
einfacher und ich hoffe dass das gut
begründet wird aber dass meine
auffassung etwas einfacher nutzen dass
dieser krieg uns natürlich noch mal ganz
anders herausfordert was die nationale
oder die europäische sicherheit angeht
das heißt wir können auch die ausnahmen
im vergaberecht intensiver nutzen und
dazu kommt auch das ist glaube ich das
war ihr anderer punkt ein verändertes
bewusstsein schlagartig manche
bezeichnen das als den ukraine schock
oder der bundeskanzler hat von einer
zeitenwende gesprochen natürlich durch
den krieg in der ukraine den brutalen
angriffs krieg in unserer unmittelbaren
nähe mit der gefahr inwieweit ist die
nato auch involviert wie können wir die
nato-mitgliedstaaten in der an der
ostflanke schützen schärft natürlich das
bewusstsein dafür wie wichtig auch
militärische abschreckung ist und wie
wichtig es ist dass die bundeswehr flott
gemacht wird eine schlagkräftige moderne
armee ist in der nato und dieses
bewusstsein trägt natürlich auch die
notwendigen veränderungen erstens bei
der finanzierung aber zweitens auch bei
der veränderung der rechtlichen
grundlagen und das lässt mich
optimistisch sein
er wickelt
jetzt wahlen würde ich gerne direkt an
der stelle einen haken es war ja ein
dauerbrenner auch all ihre vorgänger die
persönliche ausrüstung
ich erinnere mich glaube es war der
letzte
wehrbeauftragten bericht von herrn
badelt wo er die stufen der beschaffung
einer flieger kombi
durch seziert hat was glaube ich sechs
schritte mindestens waren das hat ja nur
mit geld wenig zu tun haben sie denn da
auch schon vor dem ukraine schock
irgendeine veränderung die bereitschaft
zur veränderung auf diesen da im grunde
genommen finanziell weitgehend
unerheblichen level sehen können oder
ist der mindset ziemlich weit
verknöchert das wäre die eine frage die
andere sie haben wieder die
203.000 zielgröße der bundeswehr erwähnt
da fehlen noch ein paar
vor der ukraine war einst so die
vermutung die bundeswehr müsse sich
darauf einstellen er eben nicht auf
203.000 sondern bei der jetzigen größe
zu verharren ist denn das festhalten an
dieser größe sinnvoll und ist es
realistisch aus ihrer sicht
herr wie gold sie haben ein wichtiges
stichwort genannt der mindset und das
halte ich für ganz entscheidend deswegen
habe ich ja bisher auch immer gesagt
aufs geld allein kommt es nicht an und
ich bin auch froh und dankbar dass alle
die jetzt über das geld sprechendes
immer verbinden mit der dringenden
aufforderung an dem ganzen
beschaffungsprozess etwas zu verändern
und das wurde früher glaube ich auch
häufig in sonntagsreden oder wenn der
bericht des wehrbeauftragten vorgestellt
wurden immer wieder
hat aber das ist ziemlich beharrlich das
gesamte system und deswegen müssen wir
den mindset verändern alle müssen
wirklich flexibel alle ihre guten ideen
dafür einsetzen wie es möglich gemacht
wird und nicht nur aufschreiben welche
zehn gründe dagegen sprechen es so oder
so zu machen und dann muss man die
beschaffung glaube ich auch das ist ja
bekannt auch und so flexibilisieren dass
nicht alles ich habe es eben schon
erwähnt das stichwort alles ne goldrand
lösung alles jahrelang geplant werden
muss mit den sechs schritten bis man
dann zu einer flieger kombi kommt
sondern das muss auch deutlich gestrafft
werden aber das entscheiden ist
tatsächlich auch der mindset und ich
sagte aber auch es ist auch ein auftrag
an das ministerium und den deutschen
bundestag die rechtlichen grundlagen zu
überarbeiten wir haben das vergaberecht
was von europa vorgegeben wird und dass
es auch alles gut und richtig aber auch
sehr kleinteilig umgesetzt und anderen
mitgliedsstaaten in europa nutzen das
europäische vergaberecht deutlich
flexibler und arbeiten an vielen stellen
mit ausnahmen die das vergaberecht auch
vorsieht und deswegen verbinde ich das
auch mit dem auftrag an den deutschen
bundestag hier zu durchforsten und zu
gucken wo wir das vergaberecht
tatsächlich auch flexibler machen können
und mit dieser kombination aus
rechtlichen grundlagen mindset und einer
menge guten geld ist bin ich
optimistisch dass wir das hinkriegen und
mit dem mit dem personal das habe ich ja
eben auch schon angedeutet das ist
tatsächlich eine mammutaufgabe für die
bundeswehr aber wenn wir mal gucken das
ist die bundeswehr geschafft hat den
personalbestand trotz corona
zu halten dann war sie sehr gut in einem
chor o na ja und personal auch zu
gewinnen das muss jetzt noch besser
werden und ich sehe da tatsächlich auch
eine chance ich sehe eine chance dadurch
dass wir jetzt nochmal ukraine schock ja
möglicherweise auch mehr personen haben
die sagen ich will mich einbringe ich
will mich engagieren
das ist auch eine gelegenheit für die
bundeswehr und deswegen muss die
personalgewinnung wirklich sehr gut sein
und ganz persönlich gefragt
finde ich den aufwuchs auf
203.000 erstmal gut die ministerin hat
gesagt sie hält daran fest das ist in
der planung das soll bis 2031 erreicht
werden ich halte das erstens für eine
realistische größe wir beobachten jetzt
auch dass die bundeswehr an der einen
oder anderen stelle wirklich auch
engpässe hat es gab ja während der
koalitionsverhandlungen auch mal so die
botschaft das soll signifikant reduziert
werden und da hatte ich mir auch erlaubt
ich habe nicht alle phasen der
koalitionsverhandlungen kommentiert aber
an der stelle zu sagen ich nehme wahr
dass die bundeswehr tatsächlich an der
einen oder anderen stelle nicht zu viel
sondern deutlich zu wenig personal hat
und deswegen finde ich diese 203.000
gute realistische größe und begrüße es
erst mal wenn daran festgehalten wird
hübl magna evangelischer pressedienst
ich hab noch mal kurz eine frage zu den
zahlen zu den rechtsextremistischen
vorfällen da stehen in der
pressemitteilung etwa doppelt so hohe
zahlen
als jetzt genannt haben und auch als im
bericht stehen kann das sein und sie
hatten eben irgendwie davon gesprochen
zahlen in bearbeitung und gemeldete
fälle das lied den unterschied
vielleicht noch mal erklären also ich
habe eben die zahl
589 bearbeitet vom damals es ist so aber
das ist auch sehr unterschiedlich von
den sachverhalten erstens welche
qualität wenn ich es mal so nennen darf
die fälle haben aber auch was ich dann
tatsächlich bestätigt und wir hatten
252 meldepflichtige ereignisse und das
ist natürlich so dass erst mal etwas
gemeldet wird aus dem bereich
rechtsextremismus aber was dann daraus
folgt ob sich der verdacht bestätigt ob
die personen entlassen wir ob die person
freigesprochen wird ob sich ein
gerichtliches verfahren anschließt das
ist natürlich immer noch mal eine sache
die dann danach kommt was bestätigt sich
von den fällen und deswegen habe ich
jetzt mich eben entschieden bei meinem
vortrag die bearbeiteten fälle zu nennen
von barth und vom
die meldepflichtigen ereignisse weil das
tatsächlich die fälle sind das habe ich
ja auch vielleicht deutlich gemacht wir
bekommen mehr meldung und das ist für
mich auch ein indiz dafür dass die
bundeswehr auch sehr sensibel damit
umgeht dass es rote linien gibt aber
auch dass kameradinnen und kameraden
deutlich aufmerksamer sind als in der
vergangenheit also ich nehme die
gestiegenen fälle nicht unbedingt dafür
dass ich jetzt sagen muss es gibt ein
riesen drama und ein großes problem mit
rechtsextremismus in der bundeswehr aber
wir müssen doch aufmerksam sein denn
jeder einzelne fall ist einer zu viel
aber
immer das ist wirklich richtig verstehe
also die bearbeiteten fälle sind aus
mehreren jahren nein das waren die die
2021 bearbeitet wurden
dann habe ich tatsächlich nicht
verstanden weil das ja deutlich mehr ist
als gemeldete
also es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche
dinge zwischen den meldepflichtigen
ereignissen und den zahlen des baumarkt
das blatt geht ja hinweisen nach und hat
noch mal ein ganz anderes
instrumentarium auch in die truppe
reinzuschauen und wo etwas auffällt und
die meldepflichtigen ereignisse das sind
die dinge die von kameraden oder von
vorgesetzten gemeldet werden und die
dann über die sogenannte solar meldung
meldung über die innere und soziale lage
der bundeswehr tatsächlich auf dem
offiziellen meldeweg
uns erreichen wir bekommen die gleichen
zahlen wie alle anderen tatsächlich auch
und deswegen gibt es da ein unterschied
und das zeigt aber auch wie schwierig
das geschäft mit den zahlen es um es
ihnen auch ganz deutlich zu sagen denn
nicht alle fälle bestätigen sich das
sagte ich schon ja man muss tatsächlich
die qualität ein bisschen im blick haben
also bei den meldepflichtigen
ereignissen ist zwischen hitler große
hakenkreuz reederei bis zu einer
gruppierung die sich morgens metall
hitler begrüßt ja ist sozusagen die
ganze bandbreite dabei und deswegen muss
man da auch noch mal genauer hinschauen
herr kollege ja also was den heinrich
vom nachrichten trotzen ich habe noch
eine frage zum gesellschaftlichen
ansehen das war jetzt dieser tage auch
wieder bei manchen der demos gegen den
ukraine krieg zu beobachten dass ein
nicht ganz unerheblicher teil der
bevölkerung allem was mit bundeswehr mit
viel zu tun hat mit große ablehnung nach
wie vor begegnet trotz des ukrainisch
ochs den sie genannt haben was ist aus
ihrer sicht nötig um diesen teil der
bevölkerung zu begegnen und den ängsten
und sorgen die vielleicht diese menschen
haben
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt absolut in
ordnung und normal in unserer demokratie
dass wir über militär seine bedeutung
seine größe die herausforderung wird die
bundeswehr eingesetzt dass wir darüber
streitig diskutieren denn ich habe das
ja eben bewusst an den anfang gestellt
das schlimmste ist das interesse wir
brauchen eine wirkliche diskussion mit
und über die bundeswehr und das
allerwichtigste ist erstmal interesse
ich habe das sehr bedauert als
wehrbeauftragte dass der
bundestagswahlkampf quasi ohne
diskussion über außen verteidigungs
europapolitik geführt wurde und das ist
für die bundeswehr nicht gut wenn nicht
über sie gesprochen wird und vielleicht
will ich das mal bildlich machen es gibt
von der bundeswehr aus dieser
werbekampagne schönes plakat was ich
wunderbar finde was im eingangsbereich
des verteidigungsministeriums hängt wir
sind dafür da dass ihr gegen uns sein
könnte und das bringt es glaube ich ganz
gut auf den punkt und wenn ich mir jetzt
die friedensdemonstrationen die
großartigen
bekenntnisse zur unterstützung der
ukraine gegen den krieg angucke dann
sind da viele menschen die sehr friedens
bewegt sind und trotzdem felsenfest
davon überzeugt sind dass wir im nato
verbund gut zusammen arbeiten müssen mit
unseren partnern dass wir in der
europäischen union zusammen stehen
müssen und das ist dafür auch militär
braucht gut ausgerüstetes militär und
vielleicht darf ich auf ihre frage
schließen dass es mich auch als
wehrbeauftragte sehr gefreut hat als es
die erste blitzumfrage gab wie stehen
sie zu den hunderten milliarden euro
sondervermögen und 74 prozent der dort
befragten
gesagt haben das finden wir eine gute
idee unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
müssten bestens ausgerüstet und
vorbereitet sein um für den fall der
fälle gut gerüstet zu sein
russisch sonderregel ich habe zwei
fragen mit dem ukrainischen hintergrund
zum einen
glauben sie wirklich dass seine
bundeswehr mit einer zahl von 203.000
angehörigen in der lage wäre die
landesverteidigung deutschland zu
gewährleisten bei einem ähnlichen
angriff wie jetzt die russen auf die
ukraine gemacht haben und die zweite
vielleicht noch wichtigere frage welche
folgen hat wenn dieser angriff auf die
ukraine für die moral wird drucken das
was früher noch überhaupt nicht
vorstellbar war dass deutsche soldaten
auf russische soldaten schießen können
sich die deutschen und warfen jetzt was
vorspielen
zunächst einmal glaube ich dass mit den
203.000 soldatinnen und soldaten
unsere bundeswehr in der lage ist die
vor allem bündnisverteidigung und ich
sag gleich warum ich das so betone aber
auch die landesverteidigung gut zu
bestehen und gut vorbereitet zu sein
denn ich komme noch mal darauf zurück es
ist ja im wesentlichen eine
bündnisverteidigung das heißt wir haben
die bundeswehr im nato verbund und dort
wird auch arbeitsteilig gearbeitet nicht
alle stellen alle fähigkeiten
gleichermaßen bereit sondern das wird
abgestimmt das wird gemeinsam gemacht
und man sieht es jetzt ja auch in
litauen in rumänien wie dort
arbeitsteilig gearbeitet wird also
insofern halte ich das für einen
wichtigen und guten aber auch
ausreichenden beitrag wenn wir mit über
200.000 soldatinnen und soldaten
da in im nato verbund agieren und
vorbereitet sind zur moral in der truppe
kann ich ihnen sagen dass ich habe
natürlich direkt nach dem beginn dieses
fürchterlichen krieges mit vielen
soldatinnen und soldaten gesprochen ich
war auch in verbänden die jetzt natur
des von fonds sind und sich vorbereiten
oder auch mit den verstärkungskräfte in
litauen ist es so dass dieser krieg
natürlich soldatinnen und soldaten noch
mal ganz anders betrifft und beschäftigt
als dass uns alle tot und natürlich
kommt dazu dass ihnen sehr bewusst wird
was ihnen eigentlich immer bewusst ist
aber natürlich ist es jetzt sehr konkret
was es bedeutet soldat oder soldatin zu
sein und dass sie im zweifel mit ihrem
leben für den auftrag ein stehen und das
ist zum beispiel den kräften in litauen
sehr bewusst dass die bedrohung sehr
konkret ist und deswegen kann ich ihnen
sagen aus den gesprächen die ich geführt
habe unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
sind vorbereitet sie haben eine gute
moral sie neben den auftrag an und sie
handeln mit den partnern innerhalb der
nato im europäischen verbund seit' an
seit' dafür erstens zu verhindern dass
der krieg sich ausweitet und nato länder
betroffen sind aber auch vorbereitet zu
sein
für den ernstfall und entsprechend auch
die abschreckung sehr ernst nehmen und
sich individuell auch gut darauf
vorbereiten herr jung
nur zwei nachfragen sie hatten vor fünf
minuten gesagt das hat mich sehr
überrascht dass es kein großes problem
mit rechtsextremen gibt in der
bundeswehr haben sie das wirklich ernst
gemeint nein das ich habe als ich gesagt
habe ich schon gedacht das könnten sie
missverstehen sondern natürlich gibt es
ein problem erstens in unserer gesamten
gesellschaft mit rechtsextremismus das
ist die größte herausforderung im
bereich von rechtsextremismus und es
gibt auch ein problem mit
rechtsextremismus in der bundeswehr und
ich habe das ja auch extra als thema
herausgegriffen um zu sagen
das hat uns nicht nur in den letzten
jahren sondern auch im jahr 2021
intensiv beschäftigt ich wollte nur
sagen dass die zahl die steigen nicht
ein zeichen dafür sind dass das problem
größer geworden ist oder anlass für
drama ist sondern die zahl gestiegenen
zahlen zeigen mir und zu dieser
bewertung komme ich dass die bundeswehr
sensibler damit umgeht die
aufmerksamkeit viel größer ist dass
soldatinnen und soldaten ist nicht als
denunziatorischen finden wenn sie dinge
melden sondern als ausdruck von guter
kameradschaft von gutem soldatischen
ethos auch und dass die bundeswehr auch
gezeigt hat in den letzten jahren nach
den schlimmen fällen die es in der
bundeswehr gegeben gegeben hat von frank
ua über die schweiz kaufs party beim ksk
und so weiter die fälle sind bekannt
dass die bundeswehr auch ein dran
gearbeitet hat zügige aufzuklären rote
linien klar zu machen klar und deutlich
zu sanktionieren und auch intensiv an
der prävention arbeitet und das wollte
ich insofern positiv hervorheben
natürlich bleibt das eine
herausforderung für die truppe und zwar
schon zu beginn an deswegen ist es gut
dass es eine sicherheitsüberprüfung ganz
am anfang gibt und soldatinnen und
soldaten per sonen gar nicht erst
soldatinnen und soldaten werden die
bereits rechtsextrem sind oder
entsprechend unterwegs sind dass die
direkt herausgefischt werden also das
bleibt weiter ein auftrag für alle in
der truppe für das banat und für alle
die damit beschäftigt sind also ich
wollte in diesem sinne nicht
missverstanden werden und
zum thema mainzer dass mainz hat ist
aktuell wir wussten jetzt auf wie
verhindern wir in deutschland dass die
gesellschaft nicht mit militarisiert
wird vögel andere westliche gesellschaft
wo viel viel geld ausgeben würde für
militär die sind auch militarisierte und
kennen andere form von militär auch in
der gesellschaft wie verhindern wir dass
wie verändern wir das historische
deutsche mindset fehler nicht
wiederholen
vielen dank wir haben vor allen dingen
etwas was andere länder nicht in diesem
maße haben wir haben nämlich eine
parlaments unsere bundeswehr bekommt
ihren auftrag vom deutschen bundestag
und das ist ein ganz entscheidender
unterschied und das zweite ist auch das
ja ganz wichtig bei der gründung der
bundeswehr unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten sind staatsbürger und
staatsbürgerinnen in uniform und ich
finde das ist schon ein ganz ganz
wichtiger beitrag dafür dass man nicht
eben anknüpft an andere traditionen die
wenn an die wir nicht anknüpfen wollen
dass die bundeswehr eben eine in der
gesellschaft fest verankerte truppe ist
und dass unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
das auch sehr ernst nehmen und dann
kommt natürlich dazu das habe ich eben
auch schon mal angedeutet dass wir eine
intensive diskussion in der gesellschaft
brauchen unsere truppe muss getragen
werden von diskussionen aber auch von
unterstützung natürlich aus der
gesellschaft und deswegen muss ich ihnen
sagen ich mache mir keine sorgen dass es
eine militarisierung gibt sondern dass
die bundeswehr eingeordnet wird in das
wofür wir sie haben zur sicherung
unseres friedens unserer freiheit und
unserer sicherheit und ich glaube dass
das in der deutschen gesellschaft sehr
bewusst ist
frau hügel bei ihrem amtsantritt vor
zwei jahren
die die aussetzung der wehrpflicht als
ein riesen fehler bezeichnet und im
grunde ziemlich unverhohlen die
wiedereinsetzung gefordert gilt diese
position immer noch auch vor dem
hintergrund
des sondervermögens und vor dem
hintergrund des ukraine konflikt oder
krieges
ich habe 2011 das für einen fehler
gehalten und habe mir erlaubt das noch
mal zu wiederholen dass die wehrpflicht
ausgesetzt wurde wohl wissend dass wir
damals große probleme hatten
insbesondere mit der wehrgerechtigkeit
und das hielt ich damals für ein fehler
ich habe aber nie zu keinem moment und
auch heute nicht die wiedereinsetzung
der alten wehrpflicht gefordert sondern
das was mir sehr am herzen liegt ist
erstens dass es gute ideen und
überlegungen gibt wie die bundeswehr
gutes personal bekommt und dass wir
angebote machen an junge leute sich in
unserer gesellschaft zu engagieren und
das kann im sozialen bereich im
kulturellen bereich im umweltbereich
oder eben auch bei der bundeswehr sein
und deswegen habe ich damals nach kurz
nach meinem amtsantritt
gesagt ich finde debatte sehr gut wie
wir das schaffen tatsächlich
insbesondere junge leute für die
bundeswehr auch zu begeistern und gutes
personal zu bekommen und habe aber viele
viele positive rückmeldungen bekommen
sowohl aus der truppe als auch von
bürgerinnen und bürgern aber hier im
politischen berlin jedenfalls keine
rückendeckung der gestalt bekommen dass
parteien oder fraktionen gesagt haben
gute idee das diskutieren wir mal
deswegen will ich auch noch mal deutlich
sagen es geht nicht um die
wiedereinsetzung der alten wehrpflicht
und die wiedererrichtung der
kreiswehrersatzämter wir müssen die
wehrpflicht wenn auch ganz anders
diskutieren für frauen und männer und
auf der bandbreite zwischen
freiwilligkeit und nachverpflichtung
muss man zur intelligenten lösung kommen
und ich sage es nochmal das ist keine
lösung keine antwort auf den krieg in
der ukraine aber eine perspektive
debatte für die deutsche gesellschaft
und für die bundeswehr an der ich mich
jedenfalls sehr gerne beteiligen
ist ihr ziel wenn sie eine solche
debatte um wenn wir es eine allgemeine
dienstpflicht
ist ihr ziel dabei dass sie eingeführt
wird wenn auch nicht in form der alten
wehrpflicht
also ich finde es geht erstmal darum
gute angebote zu machen je mehr
freiwilligkeit umso besser je weniger
verpflichtung umso besser und wir wissen
aus den bundesfreiwilligen von dem
bundesfreiwilligendienst dass es viel
mehr junge leute gibt die sich dafür
interessieren und engagieren wollen in
der gesellschaft als wir plätze haben
und deswegen finde ich es erstmal einen
guten schritt zu sagen wir machen mal
jedem jungen menschen ein gutes angebot
sich für die gesellschaft zu engagieren
das wäre schon mal ein erster schritt
und wenn die bundeswehr dabei ist bin
ich jedenfalls sehr froh wir haben ja
auch freiwillig wehrdienst leisten in
der bundeswehr ich habe eben auch
angesprochen das programm zum beispiel
freiwilliger wehrdienst heimatschutz
sondern im letzten jahr 843 die das
angebot an genug haben das kann noch
mehr und besser werden und die
bundeswehr kann ihren teil auch dazu
beitragen gute angebote an insbesondere
junge leute zu machen dann habe ich eine
frage online von kollegen los sie sagen
die priorität sollen projekte haben die
jetzt schnell erledigt werden können hat
dann ein europäisches projekt wie skf
keine priorität mehr doch das hat eine
priorität das kann ich aus voller
überzeugung sagen weil das projekt fks
erstens sehr sehr wichtig ist nicht nur
für die deutsch-französische
zusammenarbeit sondern auch für unsere
aufstellung ein ganz wichtiges projekt
und dieses projekt ist ja bereits
vereinbart lange geplant und deswegen
ist das natürlich teil auch dieser
investition die mit dem 100 euro
milliarden sondervermögen auf den weg
gebracht werden sollen
was wir wollen schreibt vom focus frau
will sie haben ja eben den freiwilligen
wehrdienst angesprochen mir ist bewusst
dass es natürlich an die jüngere
entwicklung ist aber dennoch ist die
frage interessant ob es denn seitdem
große schneiden geräts krieg ein
stärkeres wachsendes interesse am
freiwilligen wehrdienst gibt liegen
ihnen denn dazu erste erkenntnisse vor
also ich habe noch keine zahlen dazu
deswegen kann ich jetzt noch nicht mit
zahlen aufwarten
aber das ist ja in zweierlei hinsicht
denkbar und auch durch gespräche die ich
geführt habe und so weiter absehbar es
gibt sicherlich mehr personen die sagen
ich möchte auch meinen beitrag leisten
ich sehe wie wichtig die bundeswehr ist
ich will mich da engagieren und es gibt
natürlich auch den anderen effekt das
fehlen jetzt klar wird dass wenn sie
sich für die bundeswehr interessieren
oder so dafür sogar dafür entscheiden es
eben nicht wie es vielleicht die eine
oder andere diskussion oder auch
kampagne in den letzten jahren
suggeriert hat vergleichbar ist mit
einem job in einem büro oder in einer
kfz werkstatt sondern tatsächlich es
ziemlich ernst ist und im zweifelsfall
man mit dem leben auch dafür einsteht
und diese bündnisse und
landesverteidigung keine theoretische
diskussion ist sondern sehr real ist und
deswegen haben wir so zweierlei
entwicklung was ich bisher aus meinen
gesprächen aber ich kann das wird dann
der nächste jahresbericht seien in dem
dann die zahlen stehen wie dieser
fürchterliche krieg sich ausgewirkt hat
auf die personalgewinnung der bundeswehr
herdecker
danke gold
ja das passt und schließt auch hier
direkt da war dann sie haben wir das
stichwort abschaffung der kreis für
ersatz ämter gelernt die bundeswehr hat
ja sehr sorgfältig mit der aussetzung
der wehrpflicht auch sämtliche
strukturen für reserve reservisten
einplanung usw
entsorgt sozusagen fängt jetzt an die
mühsam wieder aufzubauen bis vor wenigen
monaten wurden ausscheidende soldaten
noch nicht mal nach ihrer adresse
gefragt wo sie vielleicht erreicht wären
ob sie unter umständen vielleicht
möglicherweise doch als reservisten
etwas tun wollen
das ändert sich langsam ändert sich das
schnell genug also ist die bundeswehr
überhaupt schon gewählt aus eben
vorhandenen potenzial nämlich den
ausscheidenden soldaten eine reserve in
keiner form aufzubauen
also ich denke dass die strategie der
reserve die es ja bereits gibt und wo
konkrete pläne auch drin sind und
vorgeschlagen werden dass die erst mal
ein guter beitrag ist aber da stehen wir
erst ganz am anfang und auch der krieg
in der ukraine hat gezeigt wie wichtig
die reserve ist die jahren wesentlichen
beitrag dazu leisten kann gut
vorbereitet ausgestattet zu sein und
wenn ich mit denjenigen spreche die
reserve dienst leisten und weiß sich in
den einzelnen einheiten und verbänden
wie geschätzt und wertvoll das ist und
da muss man glaube ich an verschiedenen
stellen jetzt auch noch mal nach
schärfen was die strategie der reserve
angeht ich will mal anfangen bei der
ausstattung und ausrüstung das beklagen
viele die reserve dienst leisten dass
sie nicht das bekommen was sie brauchen
um tatsächlich diesen konkreten reserve
dienst leisten zu können das geht weiter
über die unterbringung da brauchen wir
auch haben wir an vielen stellen gar
nicht die möglichkeit ihre reserve
dienstleistungen unterzubringen da
brauchen wir auch flexible lösungen da
habe ich mich auch schon mit befasst was
da möglich ist
haben wir das auch gesehen dass zum
beispiel in der korona pandemie
bekämpfung die haben auch uns
angeschrieben viele die über 65 waren
gesagt haben ich bin noch topfit ja ich
bin arzt ärztin ich kann auch meinen
beitrag leisten ich nehme das jetzt nur
beispielhaft ja aber mit 65 ist schluss
das heißt man muss vielleicht auch noch
mal darüber nachdenken welche personen
man ganz konkret anspricht und deswegen
würde ich mal abschließend sagen wir
müssen die strategie der reserve
nachschärfen die reserve hat eine enorme
bedeutung das ist ein ganz wichtiges
potenzial und deswegen sollte es auf
jeden fall klar sein und das passiert ja
jetzt auch mit der strategie der reserve
dass alle angeschrieben werden dass alle
informiert werden und dass wir auch die
grundforderung haben und dass das
sukzessive auf wächst damit wir
tatsächlich ein gutes potenzial an
reserve dienst leisten haben und wir
verfolgen das auch mit wirklichem
augenmerk im amt auch weil sich erstes
reservistinnen und reservisten auch an
uns wenden aber ich auch in den
gesprächsrunden immer gelegenheit habe
mich mit denen auszutauschen
da habe ich dann auch noch einen
klärungsbedarf den ich auch bei vielen
auch in der truppe sehe in der
konzeption der strategie der reserve ist
ja auch der sogenannte bereitschaft fall
genannt um unterhalb des spannungs und
verteidigungsfall wo die bundesregierung
reservisten einberufen kann es ihnen ein
bisschen klarer
wo dieses instrument verortet ist und
wann es unter umständen eingesetzt wird
weil dafür ist der keine zustimmung des
parlaments erforderlich
mir ist das ehrlich gesagt nicht klar
was wie das alte frau guckt mal suchen
irgendjemand von den
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem
amt also das ist tatsächlich eine
definitionsfrage die dringend geklärt
werden muss denn wir haben ja von
entspannungs und verteidigungsfall die
mechanismen die auch gut und wichtig
sind und ich will ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen das muss auch im parlament
entschieden werden außer man hat es in
so einer so niedrigschwellig dass man
sagt bereitschafts fall ist zum beispiel
corona pandemie unterstützung oder so
was ja dann bleibt es deutlich darunter
aber alles was irgendwie relevanter ist
als das was ich jetzt eben genannt habe
muss natürlich im parlament auch
diskutiert und entschieden ich habe mich
damit bis zu ihrer frage noch nicht
intensiv befasst wie sie jetzt gemerkt
haben das hole ich aber nach unserem
gespräch nach und male gegebenenfalls
auch eine klärung dieses dieser
begrifflichkeit und eine definition an
vielen dank herr jung
möglich und auch eine politische frage
wie verhindern sie eigentlich als werbe
auch traktor und spd lerin dass sie
nicht zum schuss von der spd
verteidigungsministerin und des
spd-kanzlers werden die gefahr besteht
nicht da kann ich sie beruhigen ich
neige erstes nicht zum schoßhund oder
zur show hündin sondern die werbeauftrag
t ist komplett unabhängig und das ist
etwas was diejenigen die das amt
konzipiert haben bei der gründung sich
gut überlegt haben dass die
wehrbeauftragte oder der wehrbeauftragte
komplett unabhängig ist und ich nehme
das sehr ernst
also ich arbeite fraktionsübergreifend
ich bin ansprechbar nicht nur für die
184000 soldatinnen und soldaten sondern
für alle parteien und fraktionen da
achte ich auch sehr sorgfältig darauf
und die bundes verteidigungsministerin
weiß auch dass sie eine kritische
wehrbeauftragte hat die streng darauf
schaut ob das was sie ankündigt oder
geplant hat ob das zum wohl der
soldatinnen und soldaten ist und sie
werden auch in den weiteren jahren im
jahresbericht ein kritisches augenmerk
auf das was aus dem
verteidigungsministerium kommt finden
und das gilt in gleicher weise auch für
den bundeskanzler
ohne verständnis frage es gibt ja viele
gewerkschaft eine andere deutsche
institutionen die es für unvereinbar
halten dass man afd mitglied ist und
teil der institution kann ein soldat
eine soldatin ihrer meinung nach auf dem
mitglied sein weil wir jetzt ja von
rechtsextremismus sprechen und einer
rechtsextremen partei
also das ganz entscheidende ist ja wie
äußert sich ein soldat eine soldatin
steht er oder sie fest auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes vertritt er die werte des
grundgesetzes
und das ist für soldatinnen und soldaten
ja noch mal strenger als für andere
bürgerinnen und bürger aber
grundsätzlich neben soldatinnen und
soldaten auch das ist auch ihr
grundrecht ihr recht auf freie
meinungsäußerung war und denn sie sind
ja staatsbürgerinnen und staatsbürger in
uniform und das ist eine ganz feine
grenzziehung die ganz sorgfältig
getroffen werden muss oder kommt es
drauf an wie verhält sich der soldat die
soldaten was gibt anlass zur besorgnis
und ich würde mal sagen noch eine
parteimitgliedschaft ist noch nicht muss
man jedenfalls hinschauen aber das wird
ja auch die weitere entwicklung
beobachtungsobjekt des
verfassungsschutzes dann sein wo da die
grenze zu ziehen ist und wo die rote
linie ist aber ich bin sehr dafür jeden
einzelfall auch sorgfältig zu betrachten
ja soweit die werbe auftrag des
deutschen bundestages eva högl sie sagt
mengel und materielle defizite bei den
einsätzen der bundeswehr sein zitat
alarmierend die einsatzbereitschaft
haben sie eine nachvollziehbare
erklärung dafür weshalb ist dann trotz
dieses aufwuchses zu diesen eklatanten
mängeln lücken schwächen kommen kann sie
jetzt auch konstatiert haben
die wichtigste erklärung dafür ist dass
tatsächlich die beschaffung nicht so
funktioniert wie sie funktionieren
sollte sondern trotz des geldes und 50
milliarden ist ja grundsätzlich eine
komfortable summe im
verteidigungshaushalt und sollte auch
dazu führen dass das nötige beschafft
werden kann und deswegen ist es auch
nicht akzeptabel wenn wir feststellen
müssen dass unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten nicht alle helm schutzweste
kälte und nässeschutz haben und einem
der reichsten länder der welt
deutschland sollte es möglich sein
184000 soldatinnen und soldaten so
auszustatten dass sie alles ammann und
an der frau haben also das problem liegt
auch im system im beschaffungs system im
vergaberecht nicht nur an an dem geld
und trotzdem sage ich dass dieses
sondervermögen dringend nötig ist und
wichtiges und gutes geld für die
bundeswehr ist weil all das was sie
jetzt anschaffen muss wir haben ja zum
beispiel funkgeräte die 30 jahre alt
sind wir haben großes gerät was zum teil
50 jahre alt ist ja der marder
beispielsweise was dringend ersetzt und
erneuert werden muss nachfolge tornado
ist ja gerade gestern entschieden worden
und darüber gesprochen worden die
tornados fliegen nur noch bis 2030 das
braucht alles so viel geld um das zu
modernisieren und wieder flott zu machen
dass dieses geld auf jeden fall in der
truppe erstens gut investiert ist für
frieden und freiheit und sicherheit und
zweitens auch dringend benötigt wird
nachfrage noch mal auf die fast 60
prozentige steigerung des wertes
zurückzukommen können sie uns zwei drei
beispiele dafür denn geld das vorhanden
war sozusagen versichert ist unsinnig
fehlerhaft ausgegeben wurde irgendwo
muss es ja geblieben sein
also
vor allen dingen stellen wir fest dass
manche dinge über lang dauern nicht also
gerade ich komme noch einmal auf die
unmittelbare ausstattung zu sprechen
also das ist so schwer ist einen sprung
helm zu beschaffen in der truppe und
dass die fallschirmspringer und
fallschirmjäger immer noch darunter
leiden dass sie keinen helm haben und
der tüv auch den stempel nicht mehr auf
den helm macht sondern der abgegeben
werden muss das ist ein unding oder dass
wir hatten eben schon das beispiel
flieger kombi was herr wie gold genutzt
hat ja also dass es halt so lange dauert
bis dinge entwickelt werden geplant
werden oder dass dinge entwickelt werden
auch das hatten wir schon ich meine das
war beim rucksack die der dann
entwickelt wurde der rucksack und dann
von der truppe nicht abgenommen wurde
weil er doch irgendwie nicht praktikabel
war deswegen das petit um so viel wie
möglich in die truppe reinhören so viel
wie möglich nachfragen so viel wie
möglich am markt besorgen so wenig wie
möglich speziell für deutschland
entwickeln sondern auch gucken was die
partner und partnerinnen die anderen
länder nutzen und angeschafft haben und
da gibt es wirklich unzählige beispiele
die auch immer die jahresberichte über
die jahre gefüllt haben wo das geld
tatsächlich nicht gut investiert wurde
und weswegen die truppe klagt und sagt
das kommt nicht rechtzeitig bei uns an
gibt es sollte herr kollege
max wieder weg von der wirtschaftswoche
ein
hauptargument ist jetzt die ganze zeit
gebracht weil es ja dieser jungfrau 346
also deshalb ich jetzt nicht verstanden
wenn der hauptargumente das gebracht
wird ist ja dieser iv 3
sie haben wir gerade das system benannt
nationale sicherheitslage die franzosen
machen ist so
jetzt ist aber viele dieser maßnahmen
zeitlich begrenzt
nachhaltig finden sie denn diese regel
oder glauben sie nicht dass wir dann in
ein paar jahren wenn die sicherheitslage
es ich auch nicht entspannt hat die dann
in seinem probleme wieder waren rutschen
das ist eine logischerweise sehr
berechtigte frage aber das wichtig ist
doch dass wir jetzt erstmal nutzen denn
das ist ja brutal dass man das so sagen
muss jetzt aber der krieg in der ukraine
gibt uns die möglichkeit auch juristisch
sorgfältig zu begründen warum wir diese
im
346 eu vorgesehenen ausnahmen auch
nutzen können und wie lange das dauert
wie lange man begründen kann dass es
eine an die nationale sicherheitslage
erfordert das wird auch im europäischen
rahmen zu besprechen sein denn das geht
ja den anderen mitgliedstaaten ganz
genauso und es wird auch im europäischen
rahmen darüber ja eine diskussion
erfolgen wie schaffen wir es unsere
jeweiligen streitkräfte so gut
aufzustellen dass wir als europäer
unseren beitrag leisten können da geht
es ja auch um die rollenverteilung mit
den usa im rahmen der nato und andere
fragen so dass ich für die nächsten
jahre erwartet dass diese diskussion
auch im europäischen rahmen geführt
werden auch die strategischen
überlegungen die europa an stellt das
sind ja alles fragen die damit
einhergehen deswegen mache ich mir sage
ich mal auf ihre frage um die befristung
im moment keine sorgen sondern sehe es
als positiv an dass diese ausnahme auch
von deutschland künftig genutzt wird
ich habe jetzt keine weiteren fragen
danke ich roque und lang erinnerte ihn
und ließ pressekontakt herzlichen dank